so how come you waited till you were 30
to put out your first album [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
[Music]
got your thumb I don't know I guess I
mean in my 20s that's when I really
started going hard at it like my homie
he had a lot of money and [ __ ] like this
he was doing like you know whatever but
he was willing to invest in my [ __ ] so
you know we made like I created a group
called Reservoir Dogs we made an album
and then we would shot this album
everywhere and then he was like you know
he do trips and go places everywhere so
then he came to New York one time and
actually just went to the universal
building and was passing out my demo and
he actually met you remember the rapper
that was signed to um DMX bizarre Royale
no but Zar Royale got my demo and he was
like [ __ ] that I know who to take you to
and he took um he took he took my guy to
Rockefeller and it was the a r at
Rockefeller at the time he was an 18
year old a r Travis conversation with
him yesterday he was like you know he
shouldn't even been doing it like he was
way too young to be doing this [ __ ] but
he knew [ __ ] so he took my demo to him
and then him he listened to it but he
was just like you know it was a group
but he was like nah the group is that
one where's Danny at though well him so
he would talk to me the next thing I
know I got a relationship with him and
we would talk back and forth and I would
catch Greyhounds I'll catch the
Greyhound bus out to New York this is
way before cell phones I would have to
get here call him on the pay phone I
gotta go to Crown Heights Brooklyn
Park's back in Utica now you know what
I'm saying like I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm doing I'm at a Port Authority
[ __ ] using pay phones and [ __ ] yeah
you know and then he would take me to
Studios just around but like I said he's
still working at Rockefeller so what
we've been doing at the time we were
using you know [ __ ] who have
these ill-s budgets like I would be
recording on camera in time camera I
don't even know what the [ __ ] is going
on we're going to Sony Studios he ain't
showed up yet they can't even knock out
a song real quick I'll go in the booth
knock that [ __ ] out real quick camera
didn't show up they didn't even know we
did nothing oh wow so that's how I made
like a few of my first mixtapes was just
us sneaking time crazy you know so this
is actually before I got locked up too
yeah so I was coming out here and I was
you know making mistakes I would come
out here for like maybe three four days
go back home with a whole mixtape so
this was my studio
so when every time I wanted to make a
project I got to come out to New York
you know I'm weird still time from
artists and [ __ ] like that because they
were showing up late yeah or they don't
show up there was time being there and
then you can order food on the budget
for chicken wings fried hard
who is making that beats and producing
it we're just getting at this time you
know he worked at the label so he can
beat tapes from everywhere I got you so
we just he just he coming through with a
whole full of [ __ ] of beat CDs that he's
getting that they sent into camera yeah
but he like what's up man I've been
going through them finding some raps
that I got but I'm gonna put some songs
together real quick so it was like it
was real like Rush
but it taught me how to be quick in the
studio and then how many years is this
that you're doing this I feel like we
did that for like two three years and
then you find my first like Detroit
State of my mixtapes that was all
recorded that way and did Detroit [ __ ]
with you heavy first they hated my guts
really yeah why because I wore tight ass
pants and just was I was like the weird
black dude oh did you always dress a
little different always and was there
any issue with that always what do you
mean I mean it was always a dangerous
but black people oppressed you like I
couldn't go any I mean one time just
being like I was wearing like the
tightest [ __ ] like Carolina blue
skinny jeans they're like and I'm going
to Little Caesars to get like a hot and
ready or some [ __ ] and just a hood ass
[ __ ] he ain't got no shirt over the net
he just walk in look at me like that's
[ __ ] gay
that's the trade [ __ ] and I'm laughing
let me get out of here so I just
wouldn't go places I wouldn't you know
but when I it would give me a validation
because then when I would go to New York
or I'd go to L.A felt normal because
everybody else dressed like that too
yeah yeah it was just my city was slow
to catch up but now you go to Detroit
everybody wears skinny jeans yeah you
know I'm fat now they can't even [ __ ]
work [ __ ] got booty dude
interesting okay so it starts with
Detroit come around
to me yeah I mean I'm from Michigan
Michigan came around I don't think
Detroit ever did you feel what I'm
saying and that's cool too because I can
go there and be comfortable because the
thing is about Detroit it's like an
attitude I don't give a [ __ ] who you are
like it's not like a celebrity Detroit
plays everybody no one's going to give
you like so when I go there
and I can hang out anywhere I want to
and you can know who I am and you're not
going to acknowledge it right okay I
don't have no no one's coming up you
want to take a picture everybody's like
oh damn [ __ ] Danny really I'm just safe
to be like that yeah you prefer because
there's other rappers that don't have
that and everybody's running up on doing
[ __ ] and that's I'd rather be famous in
New York than Detroit because it's more
dangerous to be famous in Detroit
so I'm I think I'm older too so I think
they kind of look at me like a OG kind
of yeah so it's like just see me around
and [ __ ] like so the only people that
really do [ __ ] with me is like the
little white kids and [ __ ] like really
yeah so like the [ __ ] the hood [ __ ]
or even like going to like even like
when I moved to Austin Texas like
like going to restaurants and they're
like cop my meals are like I'll go into
a restaurant they'll just throw my whole
album on Wow going to a party like Danny
Brown oh my God free drinks all night ah
that [ __ ] would never happen with Timmy
in Detroit really and I think I would
rather have it that way yeah security
wise yes because one you if it's like
that for you in Detroit you want to step
from another doing something and you got
family there and [ __ ] too like yeah I
have a 21 year old daughter you know
what I'm saying oh [ __ ]
yeah
where does she live in Detroit she's
still back there yeah all right so where
is he I don't know I guess that's
something you really got to consider
especially if you're like Hood famous
because Detroit never been to see that
was that's not even Detroit you see what
happens in La all the time like people
getting but see the thing is I think
about Detroit is that it's not an
entertainment industry there yeah you
didn't make it anymore I mean we
announced the internet you can do
whatever you want but back then you had
to go to La you had to go to New York no
one's you not about to get a record deal
releasing your music around the city and
hanging out you know
so it was always about going to the
places and me going these other places
expanded my mind on what [ __ ] was going
on yeah yeah I'm saying so when I hang
out living in New York for like two
three months of living in L.A for two
children didn't come back to Detroit
seeing how [ __ ] dress and [ __ ] like
that the women everything was like y'all
don't even know what's going on right
now bro it's actually bigger than the
internet this [ __ ] is bigger than yes
it's bigger than this so I already was
thinking you know so I was always like
Outsider kind of in that situation when
people looked at me like but it was a
thing where I would people looked at me
and I was cool because
you see me like dressing weird or
something but just because of my how
long I've been doing and everything but
damn that [ __ ] look [ __ ] up but I know
two years later I'm gonna be wearing it
too so people kind of respected me
because that's how it happened yeah like
you know yeah so all like Brands and
stuff like I'll be wearing that [ __ ]
years before I don't even wear it no
more then everybody started wearing it
why fashion why do you think you were
drawn to that early my dad my dad was
just super into fashion I had young
parents who that's what made me so ill
in high school like my dad all that [ __ ]
he's like Versace I wore a mink coat to
school one time gator boots up to my
knees so this was in high school before
you're famous nothing yes 15 years old
stole my dad mink coating gator boots
and wore it to school and didn't talk to
anybody you were a shy kid right and was
shy
whoa shut down excuse me
what the [ __ ] is going on with you one
of my teachers passed me because I had a
Movado watch
I can't make this up Miss McFadden where
where's the confidence come from to do
it usually at that age this is you know
kids are dealing with insecurity and
again trying to fit in they want to be
one of the group and you're shy which
usually is insecurity but then you're so
confident in this other stuff that's
[ __ ] up I never thought about that
this is like a therapy session yeah how
did that happen I don't know I think I
was always kind of maybe maybe okay I
think it came from the rap
so I'm always thinking I'm being a
rapper yeah yeah me wearing a mink coat
and Gators to school was like [ __ ] I'm
a rapper and you're qualified because of
your skill so like once you're cool like
Tom Brady can dress however he wants
because he got seven rings yeah it don't
matter whatever he wears is what you
should wear if you want to win seven
rings so once they know that you're nice
at rap and you already battled everybody
beat everybody you could come to school
and the Gators in the making I think I
was always just trying to be a rapper
before I was actually around but so much
of the rapper Persona as being outgoing
the way you are now yeah you're a rapper
now in the way you act Entertainer at
least back then you weren't what's that
and I was scared to tell people about it
too yeah you would only do it that makes
you would wait for the opportunity you
go to a new school wouldn't say [ __ ] to
anybody and then finally when the
opportunity came around then you would
Flex on everybody but maybe you enjoyed
that maybe you enjoyed like being the
outcast and winning people over oh he
can't do anything he dresses where he
looks weird and then boom I think I just
always just I hope I held myself up high
in essence and I always would be
embarrassed to be like to try to like
you should like me for me I don't have
to like show conform to you yeah I have
to show you some cool [ __ ] that I can do
to make you like want to [ __ ] with me no
it's just like because I wear a mixing
gator boots
like I'll wear like Versace to school
and [ __ ] like I was that kid and
what was extra crazy too
um you know working in Detroit you have
to be like 16. I had my first job at
like 13. uh a lot of my application
doing what 16 dishwashing Water World
yeah you were still in Water World I
used to work at buffets we're making 450
an hour but no one had jobs at my age
yeah so then you had money so I had
money yeah and I would just get it in
all ones
my paycheck probably be like 200 working
40 hours but I would just get a hundred
dollars I get a hundred dollar bill and
I'll have a whole bunch of ones and I'll
be in school with this bankroll all the
time
money on me yeah and it was it was just
a weird thing man okay you're in Detroit
Eminem starts to explode did Detroit
give it up for him or did that come from
the outside first
it came from outside first definitely
really but I would say when Eminem came
out it gave me hope
explain because I was like damn my [ __ ]
from Detroit made it yeah I changed my
whole rap style
after that like the whole office thing
Brown let's come from me here I'm like
oh this is about to be a style of
Detroit you know every city hasn't had
any sound yeah I'm like he's about to be
the the spearhead of this [ __ ] so let me
convert to this song like I probably
didn't rap like the way I rap now before
Eminem came out and I just study Eminem
tried to rap I would literally just try
to rap like Eminem and what are your
thoughts on him I feel bad about how
they try to treat him now yeah it fits
and I feel
I feel like this is the most purest of
him being in hip-hop to be honest
because he's just being he's having fun
he don't have no pressure
to like make hit songs or like to be
like a big rapper and I feel like before
you had all that [ __ ] now he's obviously
just making music to have fun because he
got all the money in the world and
everybody's not you know they're trying
to make him like a meme and like joke on
him and [ __ ] and yeah that type of [ __ ]
would make me not want to make music
right you know and the fact that he's
still making music like [ __ ] everybody
but he probably is not an internet guy
like we are you know yeah you probably
don't see none of that [ __ ] but yeah
that [ __ ] it kind of hurts my heart man
because I'd be like man he don't deserve
that [ __ ] huh did you ever see him
around and meet him he did uh I met him
a few times I played a real bad show one
time
um I opened for him and um I was like
it's opening that for like a little bit
oh really yeah I played my biggest show
I played was opening for him in Wembley
at Wembley Stadium [ __ ] it's an amazing
show like 100 000 people but one time I
did too much [ __ ] Adderall
and I just was sad and [ __ ] and I don't
know it just was going through a lot of
[ __ ] and I had to open for him and I
played the show it was actually I
remember it was me run the jewels rush
to him and I was just playing the show
and just the crowd it's like it's a fire
show it was like a crazy shoot and they
just wasn't [ __ ] with me really yeah
you know type of [ __ ] and that's just
one of those songs I was like you know
what [ __ ] this [ __ ] I want to do this
[ __ ] and I just threw the mic in the
crowd walked upstairs and yeah I've been
fired everything
you can't explain to Eminem that you
were doing too many drugs and that
caused problems he wouldn't have exactly
you don't want that [ __ ] around him yeah
yeah oh because he's trying to stay away
from it yeah
dog you're sober even though it's time
whosoever no I don't I don't do pills
anymore though I don't that's good I
don't do that yeah but I think I told
you me moving Us in Texas I'm definitely
I mean of course I might do something
socially uh hanging out with people and
I know you don't really you haven't
taken Austin as you're home you keep
calling it Austin Texas
that sounds like some [ __ ] you're
visiting I'm living in New York New York
by the way yeah
I guess you right I'm not meaning to do
that yeah yeah moving to Austin Texas
this goes together so cool y'all miss
that Detroit Water right there
[Laughter]